हेलो एवरीवन
फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो
प्लीज मुझे चैट में बता दीजिए। सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
बताइए।
अगर सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है तो
प्लीज यस या नो चैट में बता दीजिए।
ओके
तो प्रीवियस क्लास में किसी का कोई डाउट
है?
प्रीवियस क्लास में किसी का कोई डाउट है?
यू एनी डाउट इन द प्रीवियस क्लास
अभी तक स्टूडेंट आए ही नहीं यार। कहां चले
गए?
फॉर योर काइंड इंफॉर्मेशन। अभी जो क्लासेस
आने वाली हैं अपकमिंग
बहुत ही ज्यादा वैल्यूुएबल बहुत ही ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट और
बहुत ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन के साथ आने वाली
है क्योंकि
आज से आपकी क्लास में डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट
इनवॉल्व हो जाएगी प्रैक्टिकल सेशन में और
कई सेशन होंगे प्रैक्टिकल के
और आपको बहुत बहुत सच में बहुत मजा आने
वाला है क्योंकि यह बहुत ज्यादा
इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन होने वाले हैं आपके। तो
आई डोंट नो कि अभी भी स्टूडेंट्स क्यों
नहीं आए। मैं वही वेट कर रहा हूं। तो सबसे
पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए कि जिस-जिस को
नोट्स चाहिए क्लास में सब ने ग्रुप ज्वाइन
कर लिया?
जिस-जिस को क्लास में नोट्स चाहिए, सब ने
ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर लिया।
देखो जब तक आप लोग रिप्लाई नहीं करोगे ना
तब तक मुझे सच में नहीं पता चलेगा कि क्या
चल रहा है।
सब ने ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर लिया
फॉर योर काइंड इनेशन मैं बता देता हूं।
अगर आप लोगों को नोट्स चाहिए
डीएचई सीरीज के तो आपको क्या करना है?
सबसे पहले आपको अपने YouTube पर जाना है।
कैसे? मैं आपको बताता हूं। यह हमारी
स्क्रीन यह रहा। आपको जाना है YouTube पर।
ठीक है? YouTube पर जाना है। YouTube पर
जाने के बाद डेफोनस एकडमी पर जाना है।
तो कोई भी क्लास हो खास की क्लास नंबर 77
और क्लास नंबर 78 से हमने इन्वॉल्व किया
है। तो क्लास नंबर 77 में जाओगे। क्लास
नंबर 78 आज की क्लास में भी आप जा सकते हो
डिस्क्रिप्शन सेक्शन में। जब आप
डिस्क्रिप्शन सेशन में जाओगे वहां पर आपको
मेंशन होगा क्लासरूम नोट्स लिंक। तो जहां
यहां पर जैसे ही आप क्लिक करोगे क्लिक
करते ही यहां पर आपके सामने एक
क्या आएगा? डेस्कटॉप आइकॉन यह आएगा एक
आइकॉन आएगा क्लास नोट्स जिसमें अभी तक
सिर्फ 14 लोगों ने ज्वाइन किया है। तो
मुझे लगता है शायद इन 14 लोगों को ही
नोट्स की रिक्वायरमेंट है। आप लोगों को एक
नोट्स की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। तो आपको
क्या करना है? सिंपली ज्वाइन ग्रुप पे
क्लिक करना है और आप लोग ग्रुप में ज्वाइन
हो जाओगे। यहां पर मैंने आप लोगों के लिए
क्या क्या सोचा है? जितने भी मैं क्लासेस
आने वाली क्लासेस पढ़ाने वाला हूं और जो
भी क्लासेस
होने वाली हैं या जो क्लास हो चुकी हैं
सबके नोट्स मैं आपको यहां पर शेयर कर
दूंगा पीपीटीज ताकि आप लोग को आप लोगों को
समझ में आ जाए। तो ये चीज आई होप कि सबको
पता चल गई होगी कि आपको क्या करना है।
अंडरस्टुड
और मुझे नहीं पता कि डेली आने वाले
स्टूडेंट आज क्यों नहीं आए?
आई डोंट नो क्योंकि सारे नए स्टूडेंट
दिखाई दे रहे हैं। तो आप लोग ग्रुप को
ज्वाइन कर लीजिए अगर आपको नोट चाहिए। अगर
आपको नोट नहीं चाहिए तो कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं।
आपको ज्वाइन करने की जरूरत नहीं है। तो
चलिए फिर सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं।
ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे और सेशन कल
भी होगा, सेशन परसों भी होगा, कंटिन्यू
होगा। मतलब आज, कल, परसों तीनों दिन सेशन
होगा शाम को। और कल की टाइमिंग और परसों
की टाइमिंग आपकी अलग होगी जो अराउंड आपकी
7:30 वाली और नॉर्मल मंडे टू फ्राइडे के
बीच में अगर आपकी क्लासेस होंगी तो आपकी
जो टाइमिंग क्या रहेगी वो टाइमिंग आपकी
8 सवा5 बजे या 8:30 बजे के टाइमिंग रहेगी।
तो इट्स ओके। चलो फिर सेशन को स्टार्ट
करते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। अगर आप
लोगों को ज्वाइन करना है करो। आना है आओ
या नहीं आना तो नहीं आओ। क्या कहने की
कोशिश कर रहे हैं आप लोग? क्या आवाज नहीं
आ रही सबको मेरी?
क्या मेरी आवाज नहीं आ रही?
आवाज आ रही है ना सबको मेरी?
चलिए तो तो
आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक है वो टॉपिक आपका
सबसे पहले स्टार्ट करेंगे डिसीजन मेकिंग
स्टेटमेंट्स इन वीबीए डिसीजन मेकिंग
स्टेटमेंट्स इन वीवीए जैसे कि रियल लाइफ
में हम कोई भी डिसीजन मतलब जैसे कि हम
क्या करते हैं जब भी हम अपनी रियल लाइफ
में भी कंडीशंस के बेसिस पर क्या करते हैं
डिसीजन लेते लेते हैं। रियल लाइफ में भी
हम क्या करते हैं? कंडीशंस के बेसिस पर
डिसीजन लेते हैं। ठीक वैसे ही लॉजिक
एग्जीक्यूशन करने के लिए वीबीए में भी हम
डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स का यूज करते
हैं। अंडरस्टुड कि बिल्कुल जो
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज होती है वो हमेशा
आपकी
बिल्कुल रियल लाइफ से जुड़ी होती है। जैसे
कि यहां पर आज जो क्लास हो रही है अभी
डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स की कि जैसे आप
रियल लाइफ में क्या करते हो कि कोई
कंडीशंस है उस कंडीशंस को फुलफिल करने के
लिए उस काम को फुलफिल करने के लिए आप कोई
ना कोई डिसीजन लेते हो। सेम वैसे ही आप
क्या करना है आपको जो प्रोग्रामिंग है
वीबीए प्रोग्रामिंग है उसमें भी आप क्या
करते हो जो भी लॉजिक आप यूज करने वाले हो
कि ट्रू या फॉल्स होने पर आपका प्रोग्राम
कैसे रिएक्ट करेगा तो वो सारी चीज क्या है
आप क्या किसकी हेल्प से करते हो डिसीजन
मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट की हेल्प से करते हैं तो
चलिए फिर हम क्या करते हैं डिसीजन मेकिंग
स्टेटमेंट का मैं आपको एक वो शो कर देता
हूं चलो तो डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट क्या
होता है ठीक है डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट
होता क्या है? तो डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट
डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स
गिव ए
सबको यहां पर दिखाई दे रहा है या थोड़ा सा
साइज बढ़ाऊं? बताओ। थोड़ा सा साइज बढ़ाऊं
या दिखाई दे रहा है?
साइज बढ़ा देता हूं आप लोगों के लिए।
तो यहां पर जो है इस प्रोग्राम थोड़ा सा
कंट्रोल प्लस
चलो
ये सही है आपके लिए आपको सब कुछ क्लियर
दिखाई दे तो अभी हम
नाउ डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट गिव ए
प्रोग्राम
द गिव ए
प्रोग्राम द एबिलिटी
गिव अ प्रोग्राम एबिलिटी टू एग्जीक्यूट
स्पेसिफिक ब्लॉक टू
एग्जीक्यूट
स्पेसिफिक ब्लॉक
ऑफ कोड
स्पेसिफिक ब्लॉक ऑफ कोड
बेस्ड ऑन
वेदर ए
वेदर ए कंडीशन इवॉल्वट्स इवैलुएट्स
टू ट्रू और फॉल्स
ट्रू और फॉल्स
डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स गिव ए
प्रोग्राम द एबिलिटी टू एग्जीक्यूट
स्पेसिफिक ब्लॉक ऑफ कोड बेस्ड ऑन वेदर ए
कंडीशन इवैलुएट्स टू ट्रू और फॉल्स।
बेसिकली जो डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स
होती है, वह प्रोग्राम को यह कैपेबिलिटी
प्रोवाइड करती है कि वह किसी स्पेसिफिक
कंडीशन के ट्रू या फॉल्स होने पर उसके
हिसाब से स्पेसिफिक ब्लॉक ऑफ कोड को रन
करें। अंडरस्टुड? डिसीजन मेकिंग
स्टेटमेंट्स किसी भी प्रोग्राम को यह
कैपेबिलिटी प्रोवाइड करती हैं कि कोई एक
स्पेसिफिक कंडीशन ट्रू या फॉल्स होने पर
कौन सा स्पेसिफिक ब्लॉक ऑफ कोड रन करेगा।
यह कैपेबिलिटी प्रोवाइड कर कौन करता है?
आपकी डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स। यह
कैपेबिलिटी कौन प्रोवाइड करता है? आपकी
डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स। जो वीबीए है,
वीबीए में प्राइमरी लेवल पर पांच टाइप्स
की डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स होती हैं।
आपकी पांच टाइप की डिसीजन मेकिंग
स्टेटमेंट्स होती है वीबीए के अंदर। देयर
आर
फाइव टाइप्स ऑफ डिसीजन मेकिंग
मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स।
स्टेटमेंट्स इन वीबीए कौन-कौन सी होती है
मैं आपको अभी बता देता हूं।
सबसे पहले आती है आपकी सबसे पहला आपका
टाइप वन
सॉरी हम सीधा लिख देते हैं यहां पर आपका
टाइप वन आता है कौन सा
इफ इफ स्टेटमेंट
आपका टाइप वन में आता है इफ स्टेटमेंट
इफ स्टेटमेंट टाइप टू में आपका आता है इफ
एल्स स्टेटमेंट
आपका टाइप टू आता है इफ
एल्स स्टेटमेंट।
टाइप थ्री में आपका आता है
टाइप थ्री में आता है आपका
इफ एल्स इफ एल्स स्टेटमेंट। इफ
एल्स इफ
उसके अलावा एल्स स्टेटमेंट
सारे प्रैक्टिकल दिखाऊंगा आपको डोंट वरी
टाइप फोर में आता है आपका
नेस्टेड इफ स्टेटमेंट
नेस्टेड
इफ स्टेटमेंट
नेस्टेड इफ स्टेटमेंट्स
ओके
स्टेटमेंट टाइप फाइव में आता है आपका टाइप
फाइव में आता है आपका कौन सा स्विच
स्टेटमेंट जिसको बोलते हैं हम सेलेक्ट केस
स्टेटमेंट ठीक है
सेलेक्ट केस स्टेटमेंट
सेलेक्ट केस या स्विच स्टेटमेंट भी जिसको
हम बोल सकते हैं सेलेक्ट केस स्टेटमेंट
सेलेक्ट केस स्टेटमेंट्स। यह पांच टाइप की
डिसीजन मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स यूज की जाती
है। किसी भी प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में
नॉट ओनली वीबीए किसी भी प्रोग्रामिंग
लैंग्वेज में। ये पांच टाइप की डिसीजन
मेकिंग स्टेटमेंट्स का यूज किया जाता है।
तो लेट्स स्टार्ट फ्रॉम टाइप वन
प्रैक्टिकली। तो चलो इसको मिनिमाइज करते
हैं। इसको भी मिनिमाइज करते हैं। और नाउ
गो टू आवर गुड इवनिंग एवरीवन। गुड इवनिंग।
डोंट वरी। चिंता मत कीजिए। तो हम चलते हैं
अभी MS Word के ऊपर। MS Word के ऊपर चलते
हैं और सबसे पहले हम ओपन करते हैं अपना
ब्लैंक डॉक्यूमेंट। हम गो टू आवर डेवलपर
टैब। गो टू आवर मैक और यहां पर हम लिखते
हैं
टेक्स्ट
टेक्स्ट अंडरस्कोर डेमो। टेस्ट अंडरस्कोर
डेमो। और यहां पर हम सेलेक्ट करते हैं
पॉइंट नंबर डॉक्यूमेंट वन क्रिएट कर लेते
हैं। नाउ गुड।
यह चीज है। यह सबको दिखाई दे रहा होगा
आपकी स्क्रीन के ऊपर। तो, अभी हम एक काम
कर लेते हैं। इसको मिनिमाइज कर लेते हैं।
और सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
टाइप वन से। टाइप वन स्टेटमेंट कौन सी
हमारी? इफ स्टेटमेंट।
इफ स्टेटमेंट से हम स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं। तो इसका जो सिंटेक्स किस टाइप किस
टाइप से रहता है? इसके सिंटेक्स हम कैसे
करते हैं? तो मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। तो
ये भी कमेंट ही है हमारे लिए। तो चलिए फिर
इसका सिंटेक्स रहता है पहले आएगी आपका इफ
कीवर्ड उसके बाद यहां पर हम लिखते हैं
कंडीशन
यहां पर हम लिखते हैं कंडीशन देन उसके बाद
हम लिखते हैं देन कीवर्ड उसके बाद लिखते
हैं हम देन कीवर्ड ये भी क्या है आपकी
कमेंट लिख रहा हूं चिंता करने की जरूरत
नहीं है देन उसके बाद यहां पर क्या करते
हो आप कोड लिखते हो ठीक है यहां पर क्या
लिखते हो आप कोड लिखते हो टू एग्जीक्यूट
कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट
इफ
कंडीशन इज ट्रू। इफ कंडीशन इज ट्रू।
ओके ये आपकी स्टेटमेंट है। ये आपकी कमेंट
है। देन आपका क्या रहेगा? ए एंड एंड और
इफ। इस तरीके से आपका कंप्लीट कोड लिखा
जाता है। ये आपका सिंटेक्स है। यह आपका
सिंटेक्स है। किसका? वीबीए का। यह आपका
वीबीए का सिंटेक्स है। किसी को कोई भी
डाउट आता है तो प्लीज पूछ लेना। तो हम
यहां पे लिख दें इसको। तो ये है आपका
सिंटेक्स। ये आपका क्या है? सिंटेक्स।
सिंटेक्स किसका है? टाइप वन का।
टाइप वन का सिंटेक्स यही है। ठीक है? ये
आपका सिंटेक्स है। सबको दिखाई दे रहा है
स्क्रीन पर? क्योंकि ये ज़ूम नहीं हो सकता।
इसलिए आपको ऐसा ही दिखेगा। आप खुद से ज़ूम
कर पा रहे हो?
आप ज़ूम कर पा रहे हो ना खुद से? क्लास में
बताइए आप लोग जूम कर पा रहे हो आपके
मोबाइल पर आपके टैब पर खुद से जूम कर पा
रहे हो ना ओके चलिए गुड वेरी गुड तो उसके
बाद अब हम इसका एग्जांपल समझते हैं कि ये
प्रैक्टिकली कैसे काम होगा देखो इसका मतलब
क्या है अभी जो इफ लिखा हमने कीवर्ड उसके
बाद कंडीशन देन अगर ये कंडीशन ट्रू होगी
तो इसके अंदर जो भी कोड लिखा है वो क्या
होगा एग्जीक्यूट होगा अगर यह कंडीशन फॉल्स
है तो आपका जो कंपाइलर है इस कोड को स्किप
करके क्या करेगा? आगे बढ़ जाएगा। आगे की
जो स्टेटमेंट्स है उसके ऊपर बढ़ जाएगा। तो
चलिए फिर हम कोड लिखते हैं। कोड के सबसे
पहले हम एक वेरिएबल डिक्लेअ करते हैं।
स्कोर एक वेरिएबल डिक्लेअ किया स्कोर एज
इंटीजर।
स्कोर एन एन इंटीजर। मैंने एक वेरिएबल
डिक्लेअर किया। उसके बाद लिखा हमने स्कोर।
स्कोर इक्वल हमने लिखा 85। स्कोर इक्वल 85
देन उसके बाद लिखते हैं हम इफ स्कोर। इफ
स्कोर कंडीशन मेंशन करते हैं। ग्रेटर
इक्वल 50 ग्रेटर और इक्वल 50 देन हम क्या
करने वाले हैं? एक कंडीशन मेंशन करने हम
यूज़ करेंगे मैसेज बॉक्स का मैसेज बॉक्स।
उसके बाद हमने लिखा
कांग्रेट्स
कांग्रेचुलेशन
कांग्रेचुलेशंस।
उसके बाद हमने लिखा यू
पास द टेस्ट। यू पास द टेस्ट।
इतना ही किया। उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं?
इस सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी। उसके बाद हम क्या
करेंगे इसके अंदर? वीबी इनेशन। वीबी
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हिट एंटर देन हम इसको क्या
करने वाले हैं? अभी स्टेटमेंट बंद भी करनी
है। एंड और इफ ठीक है? एंड और इफ हमने
इसको क्या कर दिया? ऐसे कर दिया। नेक्स्ट
तो यह हो गया होगा। अब इसको हम क्या करते
हैं? एग्जीक्यूट करके देखते हैं। आई होप
कि रन होना चाहिए। चलो ओके किया।
एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं हम इसको। लो अभी तक
एग्जीक्यूट हुआ ही नहीं। व्हाट हैपन? कोई
इशू है?
नो नो
कांग्रेचुलेशन मेबी इंफॉर्मेशन मैसेज
बॉक्स सब तो सही है। टेस्ट देन देन देन
देन एनीथिंग एल्स इफ स्कोर 85 ग्रेटर देन
देन एंड इफ
एंड इफ भी सही है।
1 मिनट
नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो इसका कोई
इशू नहीं है तो
हुआ क्यों नहीं रन
अगर मैं इसको एज इट इज रन कर तो एरर आना
चाहिए ओके एंड इफ आएगा
ओके ओके ओके
तो व्हाट हैपन
एंड इफ
तो रन क्यों नहीं हुआ
आई डोंट नो व्हाई इट इज नॉट रनिंग
अगर मैं यह सब हटाऊं एक मिनट मैं इसको
कमेंट करके देख लेता हूं क्या तब यह काम
कर रहा है
अगर यह काम कर रहा है तो हम देखते हैं कि
कोई हमारी साइड में प्रॉब्लम है इफ एंड
यह रहा उसके बाद देखो अभी मैं इसको रन
करके देखूं अभी तो काम कर रही है बट
प्रॉब्लम व्हाट इज द प्रॉब्लम
एस ओके ओके नोबडी टेल मी व्हाट इज द
प्रॉब्लम किसी को पता चला क्या प्रॉब्लम
है किसी को पता चला क्या प्रॉब्लम थी मुझे
पता चल गई
मुझे पता चल गई क्या प्रॉब्लम थी
प्रॉब्लम थी हमारे वेरिएबल डिक्लेरेशन में
अंडरस्टुड ये स्कोर है और हमने क्या लिखा
है एस सी ओ आर ई स्कोर देखो देखो एरर
सिंटेक टाइप ऑफ एरर
ठीक है अब इसको हम रन करेंगे चलो ओके
कांग्रेचुलेशन यू पास द टेस्ट तो ये आपका
टाइप वन टेस्ट हो गया आपका टाइप वन हो गया
आपका टाइप वन [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अंडरस्टुड
नहीं यार आप लोग नहीं है सच में नहीं है।
कोई नहीं
ऐसे-से सरप्राइज मैंने आप लोगों के लिए
प्लान किया है इस सीरीज में। मैं आपको अभी
नहीं बताऊंगा। जो पढ़ेगा वही पढ़ेगा। आगे
बढ़ेगा। सीधी सी बात है। जो नहीं पढ़ेगा
मत बढ़ो आगे। नेक्स्ट टाइप टू पे आते हैं
हम। नेक्स्ट टाइप टू हमारा क्या रहेगा? अब
टाइप टू का सिंटेक्स लेते हैं। तो ये
सिंटेक्स हो गया। अब टाइप टू के लिए
सिंटेक्स लिखते हैं। तो चलिए फिर टाइप टू
का सिंटेक्स क्या रहेगा हमारा? तो चलो चलो
चलो एज इट इज। अब टाइप टू का सिंटेक्स
हमारा रहेगा टाइप टू
एंड टाइप टू। हमारा टाइप टू क्या था? टाइप
टू था हमारा
इफ
एल्स स्टेटमेंट।
स्टेटमेंट। इफ एल्स स्टेटमेंट। तो इसका
सिंटेक्स मेरा क्या रहेगा? यह देखते हैं।
इसका सिंटेक्स मेरा रहेगा सबसे पहले हम
क्या यूज करेंगे? इफ कंडीशन। इफ
इफ के बाद हम कंडीशन मेंशन करेंगे। देन
लिखेंगे। उसके बाद हमारे पास क्या रहेगा?
यह रहा हमारे पास आपका कोड रहेगा। आपका
कोड रहेगा। देन उसके बाद हम क्या लिखेंगे?
एल्स
एल्स कीवर्ड का यूज करेंगे। एल्स कीवर्ड
के बाद हम यूज करने वाले हैं किसका?
फिर से हम कोड लिखेंगे। उसके बाद फिर से
हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं एंड इफ। हम यूज़
करेंगे एंड और इफ। हम यूज़ करेंगे एंड और
इफ। ओके? तो, इसका भी एक एग्जांपल समझते
हैं कि इसका एग्जांपल कैसे होगा। तो,
चलिए, फिर तो, यह सारा क्या है? कोड टू
एग्जीक्यूट है। कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट।
कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट
कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट चलिए अब यहां पर क्या
करते हैं हम फिर से इंटीजर है अब क्या
यहां लिखते हैं यूजर एज डम
यूजर एज डम यूजर एज उसके बाद हमने मेंशन
किया यूजर एज में
यूजर एज हमने लिखा 16
16 उसके बाद हम कंडीशन मेंशन करते हैं। इफ
यूजर एज
कंडीशन लिखते हैं। इफ
यूजर एज ग्रेटर दैन इक्वल इक्वल टू 18 देन
आपको क्या करना है? मैसेज बॉक्स का यूज़
करना है। हम क्या करते हैं? लिखते हैं
यहां पर एक्सेस ग्रांटेड यू आर एलिजिबल टू
वोट
ओके वी इन इसमें लिखा रहेगा हम लिखने वाले
हैं एक्सेस
ग्रांटेड
उसके बाद
यू आर एलिजिबल
एलिजिबल टू व्हाट यू आर एलिजिबल टू व्हाट
ओके नाउ गुड उसके बाद हम क्या करने वाले
हैं नेक्स्ट अभी तक तो हमें क्या करना
करना था। अब चलते हैं हम एल्स कीवर्ड यहां
पर यूज़ करेंगे। एल्स के बाद हम यूज़ फिर से
लिखेंगे मैसेज बॉक्स एमएसएस जी मैसेज
बॉक्स। उसके बाद हम क्या लिखने वाले हैं?
एक्सेस डिनाइज
एक्सेस डिनाइज। क्यों? यू आर अंडर एज।
यू आर
अंडर एज। उसके बाद अंडर एज लिख दिया हमने।
गुड। वी बी इन
वीबी
इंफॉर्मेशन
देन हो गया। यह भी कंडीशन मेरी कंप्लीट हो
गई। एंड इफ कर दिया हमने। अभी हम रन करके
दिखाएं आपके सामने।
चलो फिर इसको रन किया। ओके। एक्सेस डिनाइड
यू आर अंडर एज बिकॉज़ कंडीशन कौन सी
एग्जीक्यूट हुई? एल्स वाली कंडीशन आपकी
एग्जीक्यूट हुई। यह भी समझ में आ गया
आपको? यह भी आपको समझ में आ गया। टाइप
टाइप टू टाइप टू आपको समझ में आ गया
एवरीवन बताइए।
टाइप टू सबको समझ में आ गया? जल्दी से चैट
में बताओ।
ओके। अभी हम बात करते हैं टाइप थ्री की।
ठीक है? अब हम बात करते हैं टाइप थ्री की।
तो टाइप थ्री में चलो फिर टाइप थ्री की।
आपकी कौन सी थी आपकी टाइप थ्री और इनकी
बात करते हैं सिंटेक्स की।
तो चलो फिर टाइप थ्री हमारा क्या था? टाइप
थ्री था आपका
इफ
एल्स इफ
एल्स इफ और उसके बाद
फिर एल्स
स्टेटमेंट। ये आपकी स्टेटमेंट थी। चलो फिर
हम इसमें सिंटेक्स की बात करते हैं।
सिंटेक्स में क्या रहेगा? सिंटेक्स में
रहेगा सबसे इफ स्टेटमेंट उसके बाद इफ मतलब
इफ कीवर्ड कंडीशन
कंडीशन उसके बाद हम लिखेंगे कंडीशन वन
लिखते हैं यहां पर चलो कंडीशन वन उसके बाद
देन देन नेक्स्ट
यहां पे फिर कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट
कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट देन उसके बाद हम यहां
मेंशन करेंगे
एल्स इफ
एल्स ्स इफ उसके बाद कंडीशन टू
कंडीशन टू देन कीवर्ड का यूज़ करेंगे उसके
बाद हम फिर क्या करेंगे कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट
कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट उसके बाद हम लिखेंगे
एल्स कीवर्ड
एल्स देन उसके बाद फिर हमारा आएगा कोड टू
एग्जीक्यूट
जिसके अंदर हम कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट मतलब
जहां पर आप क्या करने वाले हैं? जो कंडीशन
या लॉजिक लिखने वाले हैं। उसके बाद एंड इफ
एंड इफ अंडरस्टुड? आपको ये चीज समझ में आ
गई कि अभी आपका सिंटेक्स क्या रहेगा? आपका
सिंटेक्स यह रहेगा। ठीक है? अब ये क्या
था? कोड टू एग्जीक्यूट वाले में मैं आपको
एल्स में लिख देता हूं कि एल्स का क्या
आएगा। कोड
कोड इफ
ऑल कंडीशंस आर फॉल्स।
आर फॉल्स। अगर सभी कंडीशंस फॉल्स हैं तो
आपका यह एल्स वाला कोड एग्जीक्यूट होगा।
चलो इसके ऊपर भी लिख देते हैं। आपको सबको
अच्छे से समझ में आ जाएगा। तो कैसे? अभी
हम लिखते हैं यहां पर बिल्कुल यहां पर ये
है आपका डम कीवर्ड आपका डम मतलब वेरिएबल
डिक्लेअ कर रहे हैं। तो हम लिखते हैं यहां
पर डम मार्क्स।
मार्क्स है इंटीजर और नीचे हम डिक्लअ करते
हैं मार्क्स को।
मार्क्स हमने लिखा यहां पर 75
मार्क्स 75 उसके बाद इफ
कंडीशन वन मेंशन कर इफ मार्क्स आपके
ग्रेटर देन आपके 90 है। आपके ग्रेटर देन
90 है तो क्या होगा? आपको लिखना है ग्रेड
ए। यहां पर लिखना है आपको ग्रेड ए
मैसेज बॉक्स में आपको लिखना है
ग्रेज ए ओके ग्रेज ए उसके बाद आपको कंडीशन
मेंशन करनी है कौन सी मैं आपको बताता हूं
आपकी कंडीशन रहेगी एल्स इफ
एल्स इफ उसके बाद कंडीशन मेंशन करोगे
मार्क्स इफ मार्क्स ग्रेटर देन इक्वल 75
देन आप क्या लिखोगे देन
मैसेज बॉक्स
आपको क्या करना है? ग्रेड बी
ग्रेड बी उसके बाद इसको क्लोज करना है। यह
रहा वीबी इंफॉर्मेशन
वीबी इंफॉर्मेशन
वीबी इनेशन देन आपका यूज़ करेंगे हम एल्स।
उसके बाद हम यूज़ करेंगे ओके। और भी हम यूज़
कर सकते हैं एल इफ। एल इफ मल्टीपल यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। ऐसा नहीं है एक बार में हम। तो
थर्ड कंडीशन भी मेंशन करते हैं हम यहां
पर। तो थर्ड कंडीशन मेरी क्या रहेगी? एल्स
इफ अगर मार्क्स आपके
ग्रेटर
और इक्वल आपके क्या है? 50 है तो आपका कौन
सी कंडीशन रन करेगी? यह देखते हैं। देन
आपकी कंडीशन होगी यह मैसेज बॉक्स
एंड हमने लिखा ग्रेड
सी
देन वीबी इंफॉर्मेशन
वीबी इंफॉर्मेशन अभी हम एल्स कीवर्ड मेंशन
करेंगे। अब हम एल्स के लिए कंडीशन मेंशन
करने वाले हैं। तो एल्स मैसेज बॉक्स ग्रेड
एफ हम इसको पूरे तरह से बदल देते हैं।
ग्रेड एफ मतलब फेल्ड
फेल्ड हो गया भैया। ठीक है? ग्रेड एफ और
ये आपकी कंडीशन। तो समझ में आ गया? यह
आपका एक वेरिएबल है जिसकी वैल्यू 75 है।
पहली कंडीशन यह है अगर मार्क्स 90 से
ज्यादा है ग्रेड ए आएगा मार्क्स
75 75 से ज्यादा ग्रेड बी अगर 550 या 50
से ज्यादा ग्रेड सी और अदरवाइज आप फेल हो
गए। तो ये कंडीशन है आपकी देन उसके बाद हम
इसको क्या करते हैं? रन करते हैं। जैसे
इसको रन किया तो आपकी क्या आई? ग्रेड एफ।
अब हमारे पास होगी कुछ गड़बड़।
ठीक है? कैसे गड़बड़? एफ तो नहीं आना
चाहिए था आपका एफ नहीं आना चाहिए था
क्योंकि आपकी कंडीशन में एम ए आर के एस
ओके
ये हमने क्या करना ये रहा
फिर से हमारी कुछ प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हुई थी
ये थे हमने तो ये भी हम रन किया तो ये
देखो ग्रेड बी ये हो गया आपका ग्रेड पी
ओके तो यह आपकी कौन सा था? टाइप थ्री था।
यह आपका टाइप थ्री था। और लास्ट में आपको
सिखाऊंगा टाइप फोर। बिकॉज़ उसके बाद आपको
क्या करना है? सेलेक्ट स्टेटमेंट को
ज्यादा तो हमें जरूरत नहीं है इतना ज्यादा
वो करने की क्योंकि हमें और कुछ काम नहीं
करना। हमें अपने मिलिश कोड को ही यूज़ में
लेना है। तो चलो कोई बात नहीं। हम लास्ट
टाइप फोर ही समझेंगे। टाइप फोर की हमें
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। तो अब आ जाते हैं
हम टाइप फोर या फाइव पर। तो अभी के लिए हम
इसको नीचे कर देते हैं। अब आते हैं हमारा
टाइप फोर। तो टाइप फोर हमारा क्या था?
टाइप फोर था हमारा।
यह क्यों नहीं चला? बिकॉज़ ध्यान से
देखोगे। हमने यहां पर एक एरर कही थी। एम ए
आर के एस यहां लिखा था। नीचे हमने लिखा था
एम ए के आर आर एस। मतलब ये जो एरर यहां पर
जो नाम लिखा था ना वो गलत था इसलिए नहीं
चला था। सब जगह यह नाम सही था। लेकिन हमने
क्या किया?
सब जगह हमने क्या किया? सही लिखा था।
एक्सेप्ट दिस वन और यही गलत लिख दिया तो
बाकी कोई फायदा नहीं है। तो हमारी टाइप को
एरर थी ये। तो चलो हमारा टाइप फोर हम यूज़
करने वाले हैं। टाइप फोर में हम कौन सा
नेस्टेड इफ कंडीशन का यूज़ करने वाले।
नेस्टेड इफ स्टेटमेंट्स। नेस्टेड इफ
स्टेटमेंट। नेस्टेड इफ स्टेटमेंट मतलब
क्या होता है? एक स्टेटमेंट के अंदर दूसरी
स्टेटमेंट कैसे हम लिखेंगे देखो
जैसे कि यह रहता है ऐसे हमारा इफ कंडी इफ
उसके बाद आउटर कंडीशन
आउटर
आउटर कंडीशन उसके बाद देन कीवर्ड उसके बाद
इसके अंदर हम क्या लिखने वाले हैं?
इफ कीवर्ड फिर से इनर कंडीशन
इनर कंडीशन
इनर कंडीशन फिर से देन कीवर्ड उसके बाद हम
क्या करने वाले हैं
यहां हम लिखेंगे
कोड एग्जीक्यूट्स
कोड
एग्जीक्यूट्स
ओनली
इफ
बोथ कंडीशंस आर ट्रू कि बोथ कंडीशंस आर
ट्रू। अगर दोनों कंडीशन मतलब आउटर कंडीशन
और इनर कंडीशन दोनों ट्रू है तभी यह कोड
क्या होगा आपका? रन करने वाला है। अदरवाइज़
नहीं रन करने वाला। तो अभी इसको एंड एंड
करते हैं। इनर वाले लूप को एंड कर देते
हैं कंडीशन को। देन उसके बाद आउटर को हमने
क्या करना पड़ेगा? एंड करना पड़ेगा। तो
एंड और इफ अंडरस्टुड? यह इसका सिंटेक्स
है। यह इसका सिंटेक्स है। तो नेक्स्ट चलो
इसकी भी प्रैक्टिस कर लेते हैं। चलो
एग्जांपल के तौर पर कैसे करते हैं? इसको
मैं बिल्कुल जीरो से आपको सिखा देता हूं।
क्योंकि अभी इसमें बहुत सारा कंफ्यूजन हो
जाएगा। सर आप क्या-क्या लिख रहे हो?
क्या-क्या नहीं लिख रहे हो। इसको बंद कर
देता हूं। चलो और इसको मैं ले चलता हूं
ऊपर। नाउ हमें हम मेंशन कर रहे हैं
इंटीजर। इंटीजर नहीं यूज़ करने वाले। हम
यूज़ करने वाले हैं अभी। चलो तो डम कीवर्ड
का हमने यूज़ किया और अभी हम यूज़ कर रहे
हैं हैज़ हैज़ अकाउंट
डम हैज़ अकाउंट एज बुलियन
हैज़ अकाउंट बुलियन उसके बाद एक और
वेरिएबल को हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं करेक्ट
पासवर्ड
करेक्ट पासवर्ड एज बुलियन
एज बुलियन उसके बाद हमने लिखा यहां पर हैज़
अकाउंट
स्पेलिंग देख लेना एक बार जो मैं लिख रहा
हूं एच ए एस ए डबल सी अकाउंट उसके बाद
इक्वल हमने लिखा टू इक्वल ट्रू उसके बाद
हमने लिखा करेक्ट पासवर्ड
सी ओ डबल आर ई सी टी करेक्ट
पासवर्ड
करेक्ट पासवर्ड इक्वल हमने लिखा ट्रू
ओके गुड यहां तक सही है यहां तक हमने लिख
लिया है पासवर्ड करेक्ट पासवर्ड ये वाला
ओके अभी हम मेंशन करते हैं अपनी कंडीशन इफ
हैज अकाउंट
इफ हैज अकाउंट इक्वल टू
इक्वल टू देन
इक्वल टू देन हमने क्या लिखा
देन हम क्या करने वाले हैं अभी यहां पर
लिखेंगे
इफ
उसके बाद करेक्ट पासवर्ड
इफ करेक्ट पासवर्ड
इक्वल टू
इक्वल टू देन फिर से अभी हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? एक मैसेज बॉक्स यूज़ करने वाले
हैं। मैसेज बॉक्स उसके बाद हम लिखते हैं
लॉग इन सक्सेसफुली।
लॉग इन
सक्सेसफुली। लॉग इन सक्सेसफुली
हेलो एंड यहां पर लिखते हैं वीबी इनेशन
वीबी इनेशन चलो नेक्स्ट इसको हम क्या कर
देते हैं इसके अंदर लगाते हैं एल्स कीवर्ड
एल्स
ओके एल्स
मैसेज बॉक्स
मैसेज बॉक्स उसके बाद
इनकरेक्ट पास पासवर्ड
इनकरेक्ट पासवर्ड लो देन लो यहां भी हम
क्या करते हैं वीबी क्रिटिकल वी बी
क्रिटिकल
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं नेक्स्ट अब लिखते हैं
हम एंड इफ
एंड इफ हमने यूज़ किया यहां पर अभी स्पेस
मेंशन करते हैं एंड इफ इसको हम क्लोज कर
दिया नेक्स्ट स्टेटमेंट को भी हमें क्लोज
करना है तो उसको भी हम क्या करने वाले हैं
यहां पर इसका एल्स लिखते हैं एल्स
तो अभी मैसेज बॉक्स
नाउ कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। अकाउंट
डज नॉट
डज नॉट एग्जिस्ट डज नॉट एग्जिट।
ओके नाउ उसके बाद हम लिखते हैं वीबी
एस्केलेशन मार्क्स। वीबी एक्सकिलेशन मार्क
उसके बाद एज और इफ तो हमने क्या कर दिया?
पूरा कोड लिख लिया।
चलो ये रहा आपका। तो यहां पर अगर यह
कंडीशन ट्रू है तब जो इनर कंडीशन है ये
दोनों ये टेस्ट होंगी। अगर यहीं पर फॉल्स
हो गया तो इसके अंदर आपका जो कंपाइलर है
इसको देखेगा नहीं। सीधा एल्स जो वाली
स्टेटमेंट है इसको एग्जीक्यूट कर देगा।
अगर ये ट्रू थी फिर ये कंडीशन चेक की
जाएगी। अगर ये ट्रू है तो लॉग इन
सक्सेसफुली होगा। अगर आपके फॉल्स है तो
इनकरेक्ट पासवर्ड और अगर शुरू में ही आपकी
फॉल्स है तो आपका होगा अकाउंट डज नॉट
एक्सिस्ट। ओके? अकाउंट डज नॉट एक्सिस्ट।
चलो इसको रन करके देखते हैं। लॉग इन
सक्सेसफुली बिकॉज़ दोनों कंडीशन ट्रू थी।
अभी मैं एक काम कर देता हूं। पहली कंडीशन
को फॉल्स कर देता हूं। इसको मैंने क्या कर
दिया? फॉल्स।
पहली कंडीशन को मैंने क्या कर दिया?
फॉल्स।
पहली कंडीशन को कर दिया मैंने फॉल्स। चलो
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं। अभी रन करके देखते
हैं। देखो अकाउंट डज नॉट एक्सिस्ट और देखो
आइकॉन भी बदल गया। आइकॉन भी बदल गया। और
अगर पहली कंडीशन ट्रू है। अगर पहली कंडीशन
आपकी ट्रू है और सेकंड कंडीशन आपकी फॉल्स
है। देखो तो उससे क्या होगा? उसका एल्स
यूज़ एल्स होगा।
फॉल्स।
चलो इसको भी रन करके दिखा देता हूं। नाउ
इनकरेक्ट पासवर्ड। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? चारों टाइप आपको समझ
में आ गए?
चारों टाइप आपको समझ में आ गए या नहीं आए?
चारों टाइप आपको समझ में आ गए हो तो
बताइए। अगर नहीं आए हो तो भी बता दीजिए।
आ गए चारों टाइप समझ में?
ओके। तो अभी चले हमारे नेक्स्ट टॉपिक पर।
रिपीट कहां से करना बताइए?
कौन सी चीज रिपीट करनी है? लास्ट वाला।
जगत गुरु जी लास्ट वाला रिपीट करना है
क्या
फर्स्ट वाला
जगत गुरु जी मैंने पढ़ाया था कि कंडीशन
स्टेटमेंट्स कैसे यूज करनी है बीबीए के
अंदर टाइप वन क्या होता है नॉर्मल इफ
स्टेटमेंट है कुछ देखो अगर आपको यह समझ
में आ गया ना तो सबसे पहला आपका क्या है?
यही है। ओनली यही है। सबसे पहला आपका क्या
है? ओनली इफ कंडीशन है। टाइप टू आपका इफ
एल्स कंडीशन है। टाइप थ्री आपका इफ एल्स
इफ और एल्स स्टेटमेंट है। सिंपल है।
फर्स्ट वाला बिल्कुल इजी है क्योंकि आप जब
आपको ये चीज समझ में आ गया ना ये वाला कोड
तो फिर फर्स्ट तो आपका कुछ भी नहीं है।
फर्स्ट तो आपका इतना ही है इसमें। इफ
स्टेटमेंट उसके अंदर कोड उसके बाद उसका
एंड हो गया। एल्स कीवर्ड भी नहीं है उसमें
तो अंडरस्टुड उसमें कुछ भी नहीं है। तो
चलिए अपने
इंटरेस्टेड टॉपिक पर
चलें
चलें या रहने दें?
ओके। तो अब हमारा टॉपिक है डब्ल्यूस्किप्ट
एंड वीबीए प्रैक्टिकल इंटीग्रेशन।
डब्ल्यूस्किप्ट एंड वीबीए प्रैक्टिकल
इंटीग्रेशन।
तो एक बार मैं एक काम कर लेता हूं। अभी ये
पेंसिल ओपन कर लेता हूं। नाउ नेक्स्ट।
चलिए अब तक हमने देखा कि वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर
कैसे काम करती है। यह सबको पता है। यह चीज
मैंने कई क्लास में पढ़ाया है और
प्रैक्टिकल का थर्ड सेशन है। तो
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन नंबर वन और टू में मैं
आपको
थ्योरी प्लस में प्रैक्टिकल बहुत सारी
चीजों को एक्सप्लेन किया है। तो ये चीज
आपको क्लियर हो गई होगी कि जो वीबीएस
स्क्रिप्ट है वो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस
डॉक्यूमेंट में कैसे काम करती है। लेकिन
अगर
अगर हमें Microsoft Word के दायरे से बाहर
निकलकर आपका जो Microsoft Word है इस
Microsoft Word के दायरे से बाहर निकलकर
निकलकर Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ
इंटैक्ट करना है। अगर मुझे Microsoft Word
के दायरे से बाहर निकलकर Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के साथ इंटैक्ट करना हो। जैसे कि
आपको कोई एक्सटर्नल फाइल रन करनी हो, कोई
फाइल मैनपुलेट करनी हो या फिर सिस्टम
कमांड को एग्जीक्यूट करना हो आपके
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के ऊपर। तो हम कैसे
करेंगे? तो हम कैसे करेंगे? तो इसके लिए
हम यूज़ करते हैं Windows स्क्रिप्टिंग
होस्ट के डब्लूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट को।
Windows स्क्रिप्टिंग होस्ट के डब्लू
स्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट को हम क्या करते हैं?
इसके लिए यूज करते हैं। तो चलिए आज के
सेशन में हम स्टेप बाय स्टेप देखेंगे कि
वीबीए कोड के अंदर डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट को
इंटीग्रेट और कॉल कैसे किया जाता है। ठीक
है? आज के सेशन में हम स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं कि जो आपका डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट है उसको
आपके वीबीए कोड के अंदर आपके मैक कोड के
अंदर कैसे इंटीग्रेट और कॉल किया जाता है।
तो नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते हैं। हाउ वीबीए
इंटैक्ट विद डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट एंड कॉम
कंपोनेंट्स। ठीक है? कॉम कंपोनेंट व्हेन
वी वांट टू यूज़ Windows स्क्रिप्टिंग
होस्ट टू रन एन एक्सटर्नल प्रोग्राम वी
फर्स्ट नीड टू ए वे फॉर वीबीए टू
कम्युनिकेट विद दैट एनवायरमेंट।
जब भी हम Windows स्क्रिप्टिंग होस्ट का
यूज़ करके किसी एक्सटर्नल प्रोग्राम को रन
करना चाहते हैं, तो उस केस में हमें क्या
करना है? उस केस में हमें क्या करना है?
फॉर दिस पर्पस वी कैन यूज़
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट। उस केस में
हमें क्या करना है? इसके लिए हम यूज़ करते
हैं डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट का। ठीक
है? इसके लिए हम यूज़ करते हैं किसका?
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट का। ठीक है?
नाउ सबसे पहले समझते हैं नाउ फर्स्ट ऑफ़ ऑल
हाउ वीबीए इंटैक्ट विद डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
इंसाइड ए वीबीए बेस्ड वर्क फ्लो। तो आपको
उसके लिए सबसे पहले आपको समझना होगा कि
वीबीए के अंदर डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट के साथ
कैसे इंटैक्ट किया जाता है। वीबीए के अंदर
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट के अंदर वीबीए के अंदर
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट के साथ कैसे इंटैक्ट
किया जाता है? यह चीज आपको सबसे पहले
समझनी होगी। नाउ इनसाइड वीबीए
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट एक्ट एट द ब्रिज दैट
हेल्प्स आवर ऑफिस बेस्ड लॉजिक कम्युनिकेट
कम्युनिकेशन विद द ब्रॉडर विंडोज
स्क्रिप्टिंग एनवायरमेंट मतलब क्या है कि
वीबीए के अंदर जैसा कि आपको पता है जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है आपके Microsoft
एप्लीकेशनेशंस और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स के
बीच में ब्रिज का काम करती है फॉर
कम्युनिकेशन पर्पस के लिए। अगर आपके
Microsoft एप्लीकेशनेशंस को कोई ऐसे टास्क
परफॉर्म करने हैं जिसका रिलेशन ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के साथ है। उनको ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
के साथ इंटैक्ट करना है। उस केस में हम
क्या करते हैं? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट या सी
स्क्रिप्ट. जैसे दो ब्रिज का यूज़ करते हैं
जो इनके बीच में कम्युनिकेशन के लिए काम
आने वाले हैं। ठीक है? नाम अभी बात करते
हैं
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट इज अ स्मॉल स्क्रिप्टिंग
इंजन बाय इटसेल्फ। जैसे कि आपको पता है कि
जो वीबी स्क्रिप्ट है खुद में एक छोटा सा
स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन है। बट ऑन इट्स ओन इट
कैन नॉट डायरेक्टली एक्सेस एडवांस्ड
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फीचर्स।
लेकिन यह अकेला ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर
जैसे कि फाइल क्रिएट करना, रजिस्ट्री चेंज
करना या सिस्टम कमांड जैसे फीचर्स को
एक्सेस नहीं कर सकता। खुद से टू सॉल्व दिस
प्रॉब्लम विंडज प्रोवाइड बिल्ट इन कॉम
कंपोनेंट्स। कॉम मतलब कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट
मॉडल दैट एक्सपोजेंट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
कैपेबिलिटीज। इसके लिए Windows ने कुछ
बिल्ट इन कंपोनेंट्स को प्रोवाइड किया है।
जिनका यूज़ करके हम क्या कर सकते हैं? आपके
इन फीचर्स का आपके इन फीचर्स को क्या कर
सकते हैं? एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। यूजिंग दीज़
बिल्ट इन कंपोनेंट्स वी कैन एक्सेस फीचर्स
सच एज फाइल क्रिएशन, रजिस्ट्री इंटरेक्शन
एंड सिस्टम कमांड एग्जीक्यूशन। मतलब आप
Windows के कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट का यूज़ करके क्या
कर सकते हो? आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ
इंटैक्ट कर सकते हो। उसके बाद एडमिन लेवल
के टास्क आप परफॉर्म कर सकते हो। फाइल
क्रिएट कर सकते हो। रजिस्ट्री के साथ
इंटैक्ट कर सकते हो। सिस्टम कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हो। इसका मतलब आप क्या
कर सकते हो? लोकल एनुमरेशन परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की इंफॉर्मेशन
निकाल सकते हो। कौन-कौन से पैचेस हैं वो
निकाल सकते हो। कौन सा आईपी एड्रेस यूज़ हो
रहे हैं? नेटवर्क इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकते
हो। कौन-कौन से यूज़र्स यूज़ हो रहे हैं वो
इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकते हो। कौन-कौन से
प्रोग्राम इंस्टॉल्ड है ये इंफॉर्मेशन
निकाल सकते हो। मतलब ये सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
आप एक मैक कोड की हेल्प से भी निकाल सकते
हो। अगर आप लोगों को नहीं पता हो तो ठीक
है अगर आप लोगों को नहीं पता हो तो सबसे
पहले हम समझते हैं व्हाट इज कॉम व्हाट इज
कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल ये क्या है
कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल इज ए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
आर्किटेक्चर एंड बाइनरी स्टैंडर्ड जो आपका
कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल है वो
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट का एक ऐसा आर्किटेक्चर या
बाइनरी स्टैंडर्ड है जो दैट इनेबल्स
डिफरेंट सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशनेशंस टू
कम्युनिकेट विद वन वन अनदर एंड आल्सो इट
आल्सो अलाउस एप्लीकेशनेशंस एंड कंपोनेंट
टू शेयर रिसोर्सेज एंड फंक्शनैलिटी।
बेसिकली क्या है कि जो आपका कंपोनेंट
ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल है एक ऐसा आर्किटेक्चर और
बाइनरी स्टैंडर्ड है स्टैंडर्ड है जो आपको
अलग-अलग सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशनेशंस और
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में लैंग्वेज को
आपस में इंटैक्ट करने और रिसोर्सेज शेयर
करने की परमिशन देता है। दो एप्लीकेशनेशंस
या अलग प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज आपस में
क्या कर सकते हैं? कम्युनिकेट कर सकते हैं
और रिसोर्सेज शेयर कर सकते हैं विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ ए कॉम कंपोनेंट कंपोनेंट
ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल की हेल्प से विदाउट कॉम
एव्री प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज वुड नीड
कस्टम इंटीग्रेशन कोड फॉर एव्री सेपरेट
एप्लीकेशन और कंपोनेंट इसका मतलब फॉर
एग्जांपल्स मान लीजिए Microsoft Word को
Windows फाइल एक्सप्लोरर से क्या करना है?
इंटैक्ट करना है। Microsoft Word को
Windows फाइल एक्सप्लोरर से इंटैक्ट करना
है या फिर Python प्रोग्राम को Excel पर
कंट्रोल करना है। मतलब Excel का कंट्रोल
लेना है। तो क्या होगा? अगर आपका कम कॉम
ऑब्जेक्ट्स नहीं होते। आपका कॉम
कंपोनेंट्स नहीं होते तो क्या होता? हर एक
लैंग्वेज को एक दूसरे के लिए कस्टम कोड
लिखने की जरूरत पड़ती। हर एक लैंग्वेज को
एक दूसरे के लिए कस्टम कोड लिखने की जरूरत
पड़ती। अगर आपका कॉम्ब कंपोनेंट नहीं
होता। अगर आपका कॉम कंपोनेंट नहीं होता।
इसलिए कॉम क्या करता है? कॉम वर्क्स लाइक
ए यूनिवर्सल ब्रिज और एडप्टर बिटवीन
लैंग्वेज एंड विंडोज कंपोनेंट। इसीलिए जो
आपका कॉम है कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल है।
एक यूनिवर्सल ब्रिज और अप्टर की तरह काम
करता है इन एप्लीकेशनेशंस ऑफ प्रोग्रामिंग
लैंग्वेज के बीच में। नाउ लैंग्वेज सच एज
वीबीए, पावर सेल, C++, Python, वीबी
स्क्रिप्ट कैन डायरेक्टली यूज़ द फीचर्स
एक्सपोज्ड बाय Windows कंपोनेंट थ्रू कॉम।
मतलब अब चाहे आपकी वीबीए प्रोग्रामिंग
लैंग्वेज हो, पावर सेल हो, C++ हो, Python
हो या वीबी स्क्रिप्ट कोई भी लैंग्वेज हो
वो किसी भी Windows कंपोनेंट के फीचर्स को
डायरेक्टली यूज कर सकती है विद दी हेल्प
ऑफ ए कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट आपके कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट
की हेल्प से। ठीक है? तो आई होप कि ये समझ
में आया होगा कि आपका कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट होता
क्या है? या आपका कंपोनेंट कॉम कंपोनेंट
होते क्या है? बिकॉज़ ये क्या करते हैं?
आपके एक ब्रिज का काम करते हैं। आपके एक
एप्लीकेशन से दो एप्लीकेशन में इंटरेक्शन
के लिए या एप्लीकेशन का ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
के साथ इंटरेक्शन के लिए क्या करते हैं?
वो एक ब्रिज के रूप में काम करते हैं।
अंडरस्टुड? यहां तक सबको?
यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया?
अगर यह आपको समझ में नहीं आया ना तो मैं
लिटरली सच सच बोल रहा हूं कि आपको इसके
बाद जो कोडिंग होने वाली है समझ में नहीं
आने वाली। आपको पता ही नहीं चलेगा ना कि
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट क्या है और कॉम क्या
है। तो सच बोल रहा हूं कि आप कितने भी
इसमें कोडिंग कर लेना आपको नहीं समझ में
आएगी।
नहीं समझ में आने वाला। फिर सच बोल रहा
हूं क्योंकि अभी वो समय आ गया जो आप जिस
पर्पज के लिए आप यह चीज सीख रहे हो
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स में कैसे यूज़ करना
है वो समय आ गया है। अभी मैं आपको
धीरे-धीरे आप आप सारे प्रैक्टिकल्स पे
शिफ्ट कर रहे हो। ऐसे प्रैक्टिकल शिफ्ट कर
रहे हो जो नहीं है अवेलेबल। YouTube पर तो
नहीं अवेलेबल्स है जो मैं अभी आपको करवाने
वाला हूं।
ओके तो नाउ लास्ट स्लाइड है आपके लिए।
Windows प्रोवाइड्स 100्स ऑफ कॉम
ऑब्जेक्ट्स। Windows प्रोवाइड्स 100्स ऑफ
कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट्स। अब जो Windows है,
Windows में 100्स ऑफ कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट्स होते
हैं। लेकिन ऑटोमेशंस और सिक्योरिटी
एनालिसिस के पॉइंट ऑफ़ व्यू से सबसे ज़्यादा
यूज़ होने वाले को कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट्स हैं आपका
wskip डॉट सेल सेल डॉट एप्लीकेशन
स्क्रिप्टिंग डॉट फाइल सिस्टम ऑब्जेक्ट
एफएसo msml
2.xml http या विन http रिक्वेस्ट ये कुछ
ऐसे कॉमन आपके कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट्स हैं जो सबसे
ज्यादा यूज किए जाते हैं फॉर ऑटोमेशन एंड
सिक्योरिटी एनालिसिस पर्पस से और इन सबको
इनमें से मैं कुछ को प्रैक्टिकली एग्जांपल
के साथ समझाने वाला भी हूं। ठीक है? इन
सबको प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल के साथ समझाने
वाला भी हूं। तो यहां तक अगर आपको चीज समझ
में आ गई तो मैं आपको बताता हूं। टू यूज़
एनी ऑफ दीज़ ऑब्जेक्ट्स इन मै कोड VBA मस्ट
क्रिएट ए इंस्टेंस यूजिंग क्रिएट
ऑब्जेक्ट। अगर आपको इन ऑब्जेक्ट्स को
कौन-कौन से डब्ल्यूस्किप डॉट सेल सेल डॉट
एप्लीकेशनेशंस एफएसओ या यह फिफ्थ नंबर है।
अगर इनको आपको अपने माइक्रो कोड में यूज़
करना है तो सबसे पहले आपको क्या करना
पड़ेगा? क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट फंक्शनंस का यूज
करना होगा। आपको अपने कोड में क्रिएट
ऑब्जेक्ट फंक्शनंस का यूज़ करना होगा और
उसकी हेल्प से इन सबका एक इंस्टेंस बनाना
होगा। क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट फंक्शन की हेल्प से
आपको इनका एक इंस्टेंस क्रिएट करना होगा।
वंस एन इंस्टेंस इज क्रिएटेड वीबीए कैन
कॉल दैट ऑब्जेक्ट्स मेथड्स एंड
प्रॉपर्टीज। अब अगर आपने एक बार इसका
इंस्टेंस बना लिया फिर आप उस इंस्टेंस की
हेल्प से इनके मेथड्स और प्रॉपर्टीज को
बहुत ही आसानी से यूज़ कर सकते हो और कॉल
कर सकते हो। तो दैट्स ऑल कि आपको बेसिक
आईडिया और मिल गया होगा कि
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट और इनके बीच में क्या
रिलेशन है? कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट और
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट को हम कैसे यूज़ करने
वाले हैं वो अभी हम प्रैक्टिकली देखने
वाले हैं। तो अभी तक के लिए इन चारों
स्लाइड में और अभी तक मैंने आपके सामने जो
भी डिस्कशन किया है क्या वो सब कुछ आप
सबको क्लियर है? अगर कोई डाउट है तो आपके
नेक्स्ट 1 मिनट आपको दे रहा हूं। अगर आपको
कोई डाउट पूछना है तो आप पूछ सकते हो। मैं
आपका चैट सेशन दे सकता है। आपके जो चैटिंग
है उनको देख रहा हूं मैं
और अगर क्लियर है तो प्लीज बता दीजिए कि
सर क्लियर ओम
किसी को कोई डाउट है?
एक सेकंड
ओके। तीन बंदों को दो बंदों को क्लियर है।
बाकी तीन क्लियर है।
बाकी
बाकी बताओ।
ओके। चार क्लियर है।
बाकी आई एम वेटिंग फॉर यू गाइस।
पांच
नीचे आ रही है।
बाकी क्या कर रहे हो? सो गए
या हवा में चला गया।
अभी आपने क्या अभी हम प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन में यह देखने वाले हैं कि
जो वीबीए है उसको कैसे कॉल किया जाता है।
वीबीए में डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट को कैसे कॉल
किया जाता है। तो अभी आपने एक चीज सुनी थी
यहां पर डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट इस तरीके से
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट डॉट
सेल। ठीक है? सबसे पहले हम शुरुआत इसी से
ही करेंगे क्योंकि सबसे ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
है। तो इसी से हम शुरुआत करने तो व्हाट इज
wsिपॉट सेल? यह किस ब्लॉग का नाम है? ये
किस चीज का नाम है? इस पे हम बात करने
वाले हैं। तो व्हाट इज wsिप्ट डॉट सेल? तो
चलो हम एक काम करते हैं। इस पे चलते हैं।
तो ये क्या चीज है? तो व्हाट इज
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
डॉट सेल? ये क्या चीज है? तो सबसे पहले हम
बात कर रहे हैं। मैं आपको इसके डेफिनेशन
बताता हूं। इट wsिपॉट सेल
डब्लू स्किप डॉट सेल इज ए पावरफुल
पावरफुल
बिल्ट इन Windows ऑब्जेक्ट
पावरफुल बिल्ट इन Windows
ऑब्जेक्ट इज़ ए पावरफुल बिल्ट इन Windows
ऑब्जेक्ट Windows किस स्पेलिंग में बी ओके
बिल्ट इन Windows ऑब्जेक्ट
दैट
ग्रांट्स
यू
सिस्टम लेवल एक्सेस
डायरेक्टली
विद इन द Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
विद इन द Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ठीक है
इज ए पावरफुल
बिल्ट इन विंड Windows ऑब्जेक्ट दैट
ग्रांट यू सिस्टम लेवल एक्सेस डायरेक्टली
विद इन द Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। इसका
मतलब क्या है? इसका मतलब है कि जो WSP डॉट
सेल है वो Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
अंदर एक ऐसा पावरफुल ऑब्जेक्ट है जो आपको
डायरेक्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर सिस्टम
लेवल एक्सेस प्रोवाइड करता है। आई एम
रिपीटिंग अगेन कि WS स्क्रिप्ट डॉट सेल
बेसिकली Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर
एक ऐसा पावरफुल ऑब्जेक्ट है जो आपको
डायरेक्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर सिस्टम
लेवल एक्सेस प्रोवाइड करता है। मतलब
सिस्टम लेवल एक्सेस कैसे प्रोवाइड करता
है? क्या-क्या करता है? तो हम लिखते हैं
यूजिंग
मैक और स्क्रिप्ट कोड
और स्क्रिप्ट कोड
यू कैन क्या-क्या कर सकते हो? यू कैन सबसे
पहले आप क्या कर सकते हो?
यू कैन एग्जीक्यूट सिस्टम कमांड्स।
एग्जीक्यूट
सिस्टम
कमांड साइलेंटली सिस्टम कमांड्स साइलेंटली
मतलब मींस
रन एनी कमांड्स
रन एनी कमांड लाइन प्र्ट
इन द
विंडोज बैकग्राउंड
विदाउट
ओपनिंग
विजिबल
विंडोज
ओपनिंग विज़िबल विंडोज़ मतलब क्या है?
यूजिंग मैक्रोस और स्क्रिप्ट कोड यू कैन
एग्जीक्यूट सिस्टम कमांड साइलेंटली। मतलब
आप मै कोड की हेल्प से Windows टर्मिनल पर
बैक एंड में साइलेंटली कोई भी कमांड चला
सकते हैं। कोई भी सिस्टम कमांड्स चला सकते
हैं। इसका मतलब यह है। पॉइंट नंबर टू की
बात करते हैं। यू कैन मैनेज द Windows
रजिस्ट्री। यू कैन मैनेज द
Windows रजिस्ट्री।
यू कैन मैनेज द विंडोज रजिस्ट्री मतलब
सीमलेसली
मतलब सिमलेसली
रीड
एडिट
और क्रिएट
क्रिएट न्यू रजिस्ट्री
कीज़
इसका मतलब क्या है कि आप डायरेक्टली
Windows की को रीड कर सकते हो, एडिट कर
सकते हो, अपडेट कर सकते हो या कोई नई की
ऐड कर सकते हो। अब Windows रजिस्ट्री के
अंदर कोई भी की रीड, एडिट, डिलीट और नए की
ऐड कर सकते हो। थर्ड पॉइंट क्या है? यू
कैन क्रिएट यू कैन क्रिएट कस्टम
शॉर्टकट्स।
यू कैन क्रिएट कस्टम शॉर्टकट्स। मींस
इंस्टेंटली
इंस्टेंटली जनरेट
जनरेट डॉट एल एनk शॉर्टकट
शॉर्टकट फाइल्स
ऑन योर ऑन योर डेस्कटॉप
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डेस्कटॉप और स्टार्टअप मेनू
स्टार्टअप मेनू कोई टाइप एरर हो रही है तो
प्लीज
बता देना। ओके। ऑन स्टार्टअप मेन्यू। थर्ड
पॉइंट का मतलब क्या है? कि आप डेस्कटॉप या
स्टार्टअप मेन्यू पर कोई भी कस्टम शॉर्टकट
फाइल या कोई भी कस्टम लिंक फाइल क्रिएट कर
सकते हो। जैसे हम शॉर्टकट लिंक क्रिएट
करते हैं ना डेस्कटॉप के ऊपर, किसी भी
एप्लीकेशन का, किसी भी फाइल का तो इसी
प्रकार से आप भी क्या कर सकते हो? इसकी
हेल्प से शॉर्टकट लिंक क्रिएट कर सकते हो।
मतलब समझ में आ गया होगा कि
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट बहुत ही पावरफुल बिल्ट
इन विंडोज ऑब्जेक्ट है जो आपको सिस्टम
लेवल एक्सेस प्रोवाइड करती है जिसकी हेल्प
से आप क्या कर सकते हो टर्मिनल में कोई भी
कमांड चला सकते हो बिना किसी यूजर को पॉप
अप किए प्र्ट किए अंडरस्टुड ये चीज सबको
समझ में आ गई ये चीज समझ में आ गई
ये चीज समझ में आ गई सबको
ये चीज आपको समझ में आ गई या नहीं आई?
चलिए फिर प्रैक्टिक इसका मैं आपको कैसे
क्रिएट करते हैं ऑब्जेक्ट मैं आपको बता
देता हूं इसका। तो इसका कैसे ऑब्जेक्ट
क्रिएट किया जाता है? चलो फिर चलो चलो चलो
चलो आपका टेस्ट चल रहा है। ये रहा टेस्ट
डॉक्यूमेंट चलो नाउ।
ठीक है? तो सबसे पहले आपको क्या करना है?
सबसे पहले हम यूज़ करेंगे वेरिएबल डम।
वेरिएबल का नाम यूज़ कर रहे हैं। ऑब्जेक्ट
ऑफ सेल ऑफ सेल लिखा हमने। एक वेरिएबल
डिक्लेअ किया। उसके बाद आप क्या करते हैं?
सेट वेरिएबल सेट
ऑब सेल वेरिएबल का नेम इक्वल। आपको क्या
बताया था मैंने? क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट नाम का
फंक्शन कॉल करना है आपको। तो क्रिएट
ऑब्जेक्ट
क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट देन उसके बाद आपको क्या
लिखना है उसके अंदर डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
wिप्ट
डॉट सेल डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट डॉट सेल आपको
क्या करना है उसके अंदर कॉल करना है यह
आपका क्या है डब्लू स्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
क्रिएट हो रहा है यहां पर यहां पर आपने
क्या कर लिया एक उसका इंस्टेंस क्रिएट कर
लिया डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का आपने एक यहां पर
इंस्टेंस इंस्टेंस क्रिएट कर लिया तो जैसे
जैसे मैंने अभी क्या बताया था wsp डॉट सेल
क्या है? आपका एक स्टैंडर्ड कमांड लाइन
क्या है? एक कमांड लाइन ऑब्जेक्ट है। तो
उसका आपने एक इंस्टेंस यहां पर क्रिएट कर
लिया। तो wsिप डॉट सेल। ठीक है? किसके
अंदर? ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट सेल। अब सबसे इसके
बहुत सारे पावरफुल मेथड्स होते हैं जिनका
हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं। तो इसमें सबसे पहला
पावरफुल मेथड्स है आपका डॉट रन मेथड। सबसे
पावरफुल मेथड आपका क्या है? डॉट रन मेथड।
तो हम एक काम करते हैं यहां पर यहां पर
लिखते हैं सबसे पहले।
डेमो
वन ठीक है सॉरी डेमो वन नहीं आपको यहां
लिख सकते हैं
wsिप डॉट सेल एक्सेस
ऑब्जेक्ट एक्सेस ओके उसके बाद अभी हम क्या
करते हैं एक मेथड होता है आपका एक मेथड
होता है आपका कौन सा आपको बताऊं डॉट रन
डॉट रन एक मेथड होता है। यह क्या करता है?
डॉट रन मेथड। डॉट रन मेथड क्या करता है?
डॉट रन मेथड
इज
यूज्ड टू एग्जीक्यूट
यूज्ड टू एग्जीक्यूट प्रोग्राम्स।
एग्जीक्यूट प्रोग्राम्स
स्क्रिप्ट्स
स्क्रिप्ट्स और सिस्टम कमांड्स
कमांड्स इन
आइदर
द बैकग्राउंड
और द फोरग्राउंड
विदाउट कैप्चरिंग
कैप्चरिंग देयर आउटपुट
विद कैप्चरिंग देयर आउटपुट इसका मतलब क्या
है कि डोर रन मेथड इज यूज्ड टू एग्जीक्यूट
प्रोग्राम स्क्रिप्ट सिस्टम कमांड्स इन
आइदर द बैकग्राउंड और द फॉरग्राउंड विदाउट
कैप्चरिंग देयर आउटपुट। मतलब क्या है कि
डॉट रन मेथड का यूज़ आप किसी भी प्रोग्राम,
स्क्रिप्ट या कमांड को बैकग्राउंड या
फोरग्राउंड में एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए कर
सकते हो बिना उसका आउटपुट कैप्चर किए।
मतलब इसमें उस पर्टिकुलर कमांड का आउटपुट
कैप्चर नहीं होगा। जस्ट आप कोई एप्लीकेशन
रन करनी है, आपको कोई प्रोग्राम
एग्जीक्यूट करवाना है या कोई स्क्रिप्ट
एग्जीक्यूट करवानी है। देन ओनली यू कैन
यूज़ दिस डॉट रन मेथड। आप लेकिन अगर आपको
कोई इफ कमांड का आउटपुट चाहिए, आपको कोई
टर्मिनल पर आपने क्या करना है? कोई लोकल
ग्रुप के डिटेल देखनी है या आपको सिस्टम
इनेशन देखनी है तो उस पर्पस से आप इसका
यूज़ नहीं कर सकते। तो अंडरस्टुड गाइज़? तो
इसका एक सिंटेक्स होता है। इसका भी एक
सिंटेक्स होता है। कैसे इसको यूज करना है?
तो सिंटेक्स क्या है इसका? तो सिंटेक्स की
बात करते हैं। भैया इसका सिंटेक्स मैं
आपको बिल्कुल क्लियरली समझाने वाला हूं।
चलो इसका सिंटेक्स आपका क्या रहेगा? सबसे
पहले आप यूज़ करोगे ऑब्जेक्ट। पहले आप यूज़
करोगे सिंटेक्स में ऑब्जेक्ट का नाम।
ऑब्जेक्ट के आंसर आपका जैसे कि ऑब्जेक्ट
सेल था ना? तो ऑब्जेक्ट में आप यूज़ करोगे
ऑब्सल। ऑब सेल। ठीक है? जिस किसका
ऑब्जेक्ट? इंस्टेंस डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट का
इंस्टेंस डॉट रन यूज़ करोगे डॉट रन उसके
बाद आप पहला पैरामीटर लिखते हो एसटीआर
कमांड एसटीआर कमांड ठीक है फर्स्ट
पैरामीटर कॉमा उसके बाद ये रहा इंट
विंडो स्टाइल
यह इसका सिंटेक्स है विंडो स्टाइल
विंडो स्टाइल यह इसका सिंटेक्स इंट विंडो
स्टाइल
नेक्स्ट थर्ड पैरामीटर इसका क्या है? थर्ड
पैरामीटर है बी वेट ऑन रिटर्न।
वेट ऑन रिटर्न।
अब इनका मतलब क्या होता है? मैं आपको
समझाने वाला हूं। तीनों का मतलब क्या होता
है? ये क्या है? इसका सिंटेक्स है। ये
क्या है? इसका सिंटेक्स है। तो इस
सिंटेक्स को मैं लेके चलता हूं आपके किसके
ऊपर? इस पर। ठीक है? सिंटेक्स को समझते
हैं। सिंटेक्स का मतलब क्या है भैया? यहां
पर कर दिया हमने। यह इसका सिंटेक्स है। तो
चलो फिर सिंक्स को समझ लेते हैं। तो
सिंटेक्स को समझ लेते हैं। चलो यह रहा
सिंटेक्स आपका ये रहा।
ओके परफेक्ट
ऑफसेल डॉट रन एसटीआर कमांड इंट इंडो
स्टाइल। इस सिंटेक्स को समझते हैं कि हर
एक पैरामीटर किस पर्पस से किसका क्या
पर्पस है। सबसे पहले आते हैं हम किसके
ऊपर? आपके एसटीआर
कमांड के ऊपर। एसटीआर कमांड। इसके अंदर आप
जो इसके अंदर जो आप वैल्यू देते हो
स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू देते हो। इसके अंदर आप
क्या करते हो? एक स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू मेंशन
करते हो। इसके अंदर क्या स्पेसिफाई करते
हो? इस पैरामीटर के अंदर आप एक स्ट्रिंग
वैल्यू स्पेसिफाई करते हो। ठीक है? इसके
अंदर आप कोई भी स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू स्पेसिफाई
करते हो। इसका मतलब क्या है? स्पेसिफाई
स्पेसिफाई द कमांड
और एग्जीक्यूटेबल
और एग्जीक्यूटेबल पाथ
यू वांट टू रन यू वांट टू रन जैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल
फॉर एग्जांपल आपका
नोटपड
नोटपड डॉट exc उसके या फिर आपका
cell exc ये एग्जांपल है कैलकुलेटर exc
कैलxc
मे बी यही होगा इसका पाथ इस तरीके से ओके
ये आपका फर्स्ट पैरामीटर ये क्या करता है
इसमें क्या मेंशन करते हो आप सबसे पहले इस
पैरामीटर के अंदर आप स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू
प्रोवाइड करते हो और यहां पर स्ट्रिंग
वैल्यू मतलब क्या है कि यहां पर आप वो
कमांड या एग्जीक्यूटेबल पाथ प्रोवाइड करते
हो जो आपको रन करवाना है। मतलब जो चीज़
आपको रन करवानी है, चाहे वह किसी
प्रोग्राम का नाम है, कोई स्क्रिप्ट का
पाथ है, वह आप फ़र्स्ट पैरामीटर में दोगे।
एसटीआर कमांड पैरामीटर में उसको मेंशन
करने वाले हो। तो, सेकंड का क्या मतलब हो
गया? अभी सेकंड पैरामीटर आपका क्या है?
इंट विंडो
विंडो स्टाइल। इसमें आप क्या मेंशन करते
हो? स्टाइल विंडो स्टाइल। इसके अंदर आप
क्या मेंशन करते हो? इंटीजर वैल्यू। एक
इंटीजर वैल्यू यहां पर मेंशन कर दिया। अब
कौन उस इंटीजर वैल्यू का क्या मतलब होता
है? मैं आपको बताता हूं। कौन-कौन सी
इंटीजर वैल्यू आप यूज़ कर सकते हो और किसका
क्या मतलब होता है। ठीक है? ठीक है? किसका
क्या मतलब होता है? तो यह पैरामीटर
एक्चुअल में करता क्या है? इट डिटरमाइंस
इट डिटरमाइंस
डिटरमाइन वेदर
वेदर द स्क्रिप्ट
वेदर द स्क्रिप्ट शुड
सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी गलत है ये गलत
नेक्स्ट पैरामीटर का लिख दिया मैंने ये
क्या है इट कंट्रोल्स
इट कंट्रोल्स
हाउ द विंडज़
विंडज़ इट डिस्प्लेस इज डिस्प्लेड व्हेन
द कमांड रंस व्हेन द कमांड रंस मतलब क्या
है? इसका मतलब क्या है? कि कमांड चलने के
बाद विंडोज डिस्प्ले स्टाइल क्या होगा?
स्टाइल आपको पता है ना? एक तो होता है
हिडन, नॉर्मल, मैक्सिमाइज्ड, मिनिमाइज्ड।
कि जो प्रोग्राम आप एग्जीक्यूट करवा रहे
हो उसको आप क्या करवा सकते हो? बिना यूजर
की नजरों में आए हिडन भी करवा सकते हो।
नॉर्मल विंडो के ऊपर में जो पहले से
सिस्टम की उसका साइज है उसी साइज में ओपन
हो या मिनिमाइज विंडो हो या मैक्सिमाइज
विंडो हो। तो इसमें क्या-क्या वैल्यू दे
सकते हो? सबसे पहले वैल्यू आप कौन सी दे
सकते हो? सबसे पहले वैल्यू दे सकते हो आप
जीरो। जीरो का मतलब क्या है आपका? जीरो का
मतलब हिडन विंडो। हिडन विंडो जीरो का मतलब
आपकी हिडन विंडोज हिडन विंडोज जीरो का
मतलब हिडन विंडो
विंडो
हिडन विंडो उसके बाद दूसरी वैल्यू आप क्या
दे सकते हो वन मतलब वन मतलब यहां पर मेंशन
कर सकते हो नॉर्मल विंडो नॉर्मल विंडो
नॉर्मल विंडो कौन सी आपकी जो डिफॉल्ट
विंडो होती है ना जो नॉर्मल ओपन होती है
नॉर्मल विंडो
इसका मतलब है। उसके बाद नेक्स्ट अगर आपने
टू लिखा तो क्या आएगा आपका? मिनिमाइज
विंडो। मिनिमाइज्ड विंडो। मिनिमाइज का पता
ही है आपको? मिनिमाइज विंडो मतलब जो टास्क
बार पे शो होती है। मिनिमाइज करने के बाद
जैसे कि ये रहा मैंने इसको अगर मिनिमाइज
किया तो यह क्या है? यहां पर टास्क बार पे
शो हो रही है ना? तो वही चीज है आपका
मिनिमाइज्ड विंडो। नेक्स्ट आपका क्या है?
यहां पर कौन सी? थ्री दे सकते हो। 0 1 2 3
तक ही दे सकते हो। कौन सा आपका मैक्सिमाइज
विंडो मैक्सिमाइज्ड
विंडो मैक्सिमाइज्ड विंडो आप यहां पर
मैक्सिमाइज विंडो दे सकते हो। अब आते हैं
हमारे नेक्स्ट पैरामीटर पे। कौन सा? बी
वेट ऑन रिटर्न। इसका मतलब क्या होता है?
बी वेट ऑन रिटर्न। और क्या इसमें आप दे
सकते हो? इसके अंदर आप मेंशन करते हो
क्या? बुलियन वैल्यू। ओनली बुलियन वैल्यू
आप इसके अंदर मेंशन कर सकते हो। मतलब
डिटरमाइन
मतलब डिटरमाइन
डिटरमाइंस वेदर
वेदर द स्क्रिप्ट
वेदर द स्क्रिप्ट शुड
वेट
फॉर द कमांड
टू फिनिश
कमांड टू फिनिश मतलब
यहां पर आप क्या-क्या वैल्यू दे सकते हो
सबसे पहले आप वैल्यू क्या दे सकते हैं
इसमें?
फॉल्स जो आपकी डिफॉल्ट वैल्यू होती है।
फॉल्स आपकी डिफॉल्ट वैल्यू होती है। मतलब
द स्क्रिप्ट
द स्क्रिप्ट कंटिन्यूस
कंटिन्यूस एग्जीक्यूटिंग
एग्जीक्यूटिंग द नेक्स्ट लाइन।
नेक्स्ट लाइन इमीडिएटली
इमीडिएटली
विदाउट
वेटिंग
विदाउट मीटिंग मतलब क्या है कि इस
पैरामीटर में क्या स्क्रिप्ट को कमांड
खत्म होने के बाद वेट करना चाहिए या नहीं
चाहिए यह इस पैरामीटर के बेस पर क्या होता
है डिसाइड होता है अगर फॉल्स जो आपका
डिफॉल्ट होता है स्क्रिप्ट क्या होगी
स्क्रिप्ट उसका एग्जीक्यूट होने का वेट
नहीं करेगी बल्कि वह अपने कोड को
एग्जीक्यूट करती रहेगी और
जो आपकी विंडो ओपन हुई है आपने कैलकुलेटर
ओपन किया है या जो टास्क परफॉर्म करने के
लिए बोला उसके लिए वेट नहीं करेगी
स्क्रिप्ट वो आपने जैसे ही वह कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट हुई नेक्स्ट उसके बाद कंटिन्यू
चलती रहेगी मतलब वेट नहीं करेगी या अगर
आपने ट्रू दिया ट्रू में क्या होगा आपका
ट्रू में आपका होगा
द स्क्रिप्ट
पोचि एंड वेट्स एंड वेट्स अंटिल द
एग्जीक्यूटेड
अंटिल द एग्जीक्यूटेड कमांड अंटिल द
एग्जीक्यूटेड कमांड फिनिशेस
कमांड फिनिशेस एंड क्लोजेस
एंड क्लोज का मतलब क्या है कि जब तक कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट होकर क्लोज नहीं होती
स्क्रिप्ट पॉज रहेगी
मतलब आपने यहां पर जो कमांड या जो पाथ
दिया था जब तक वह एग्जीक्यूट होकर वो
क्लोज नहीं हो जाएगा तब तक आपकी स्क्रिप्ट
पाई पर पहुंच जाएगी। अगर आपने ट्रू मेंशन
किया तो इस पैरामीटर में अगर आपने फॉल्स
मेंशन किया तो क्या होगा? वो इसके लिए वेट
नहीं करने वाली। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? ये
सबको समझ में आया ये चीज? सिंटेक्स बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। अदरवाइज यू कैन नॉट
डू एनी प्रोग्रामिंग सच प्रोग्रामिंग
बिकॉज़ इट इज ए मैनुअली और पेलोड डेवलपमेंट
की क्लासेस हैं। और आपको सच में पता चल
जाएगा कि हम एक प्रैक्टिकल भी सबका कंबाइन
प्रैक्टिकल भी करने वाले हैं और एक नहीं
कई करने वाले हैं ताकि आपको आदत बन जाए कि
मुझे कैसे कोडिंग करनी है। कैसे आपको
वीबीएस स्क्रिप्टिंग करनी है।
ओके एसटीआर कमांड स्ट्रिंग समझा दूं। देखो
मैं आपको समझा देता हूं। यह क्या करती है?
यहां पर आप क्या करते हो? जो भी आपको
प्रोग्राम एग्जीक्यूट करवाना है, जो
स्क्रिप्ट आपको एग्जीक्यूट करवानी है,
उसका फुल पाथ यहां पर आप मेंशन करते हो
स्ट्रिंग की फॉर्म में। यह क्या करता है?
यह डायरेक्ट आपके बैकग्राउंड में टर्मिनल
के ऊपर उसको या उसको सिस्टम को क्या करता
है? यह कमांड देता है आपकी उसको। अगर आपने
फॉर एग्जांपल नोटपड exc ओपन करवाना है तो
यह नोटपड exc को ओपन कर देगा तो वो जो
वैल्यू है वो आप यहां पर देते हो इसका
प्रैक्टिकल देखते हैं अभी प्रैक्टिकल
देखना है प्रैक्टिकल देखना है या नहीं
देखना बताओ प्रैक्टिकल देखने के बाद सब
कुछ समझ में आ जाएगा और इसका प्रैक्टिकल
सब इसका प्रैक्टिकल करते हैं। उसके बाद
बाकी हम कल करेंगे क्योंकि बहुत सारी
इसमें इसके इंपॉर्टेंट मेथड्स हैं जो हमें
समझने हैं। उसके बाद जो मैंने चार मोस्ट
कॉमन
पांच बताए थे मोस्ट कॉमन ऑब्जेक्ट जो यूज़
किया था मैं चार को समझाने वाला हूं। चार
को समझाने वाला हूं। तो चलिए फिर अपने
प्रैक्टिकल पर चलते हैं। प्रैक्टिकल पे
हमें या ये आपको पता चल गया सिंटेक्स।
नेक्स्ट अभी हम क्या करने वाले हैं? फिर
चलो फिर यूज़ करते हैं। ऑब्जेक्ट सेल
डॉट रन डॉट रन। ऑब्जेक्ट सेल डॉट रन। ठीक
है? डॉट रन यह स्पेलिंग इसका बड़ा रहेगा
रन का रन कैपिटल रहेगा। ठीक है? और एक एक
मिनट एक मिनट इसको पूरा फुल प्रैक्टिकली
करते हैं। तो चलो ऑब्जेक्ट सेल हो गया।
ऑब्जेक्ट सेल इसका एक क्रिएट कर लिया। तो
इसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा हूं? एक मैसेज
बॉक्स दे देता हूं। एक मैसेज बॉक्स दे
देता हूं ताकि आपको पता चल जाएगा। मैसेज
बॉक्स
डेमो वन डेमो वन
नोटपज
विल ओपन
इन मैक्सिमाइज मोड मैक्सिमाइज
मैक्सिमाइज मोड एंड द स्क्रिप्ट
एंड द स्क्रिप्ट
विल वेट
विल वेट अंटिल
अंटिल
नोटपड इज़ क्लोज्ड अंटिल नोटपड इज़ क्लोज्ड
ओके यह आपका क्या है अभी के लिए हमने एक
मैसेज बॉक्स यहां पर डाला ताकि आपको समझ
में आ जाएगा। अंडरस्टुड? चलो
उसके बाद हमने इसकी यहां पर डेफिनेशन दी
हुई है। तो ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट रन ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट
रन फर्स्ट पैरामीटर आपको मेंशन करना है जो
एग्जीक्यूट करवाना है। तो हमने लिखा नोटपड
ex आपका नोटपैड खुला खुलेगा इसमें। उसके
बाद मेंशन किया थ्री। थ्री का मतलब क्या
था? थ्री का मतलब क्या था? जल्दी बताओ।
और ट्रू का मतलब क्या था? बताओ जल्दी से
एक्सप्लेन करो मेरे को। यह
फर्स्ट पैरामीटर समझ में आ गया? सेकंड
पैरामीटर में थ्री क्यों लिखा मैंने? इसका
मतलब क्या है? बताओ जल्दी से।
इसका मतलब क्या है? टेल मी एवरीवन।
जल्दी से बताओ।
मैक्सिमाइज ब्रो मैक्सिमाइज नॉट
मिनिमाइज्ड। ठीक है? ऊपर ही लिखा है। डेमो
वन नोटपड विल ओपन इन मैक्सिमाइज मोड। द
स्क्रिप्ट विल वेट अंटिल नोटपड इज
क्लोज्ड। तो यहां तक हो गया। यह यहां पर
हमने एग्जीक्यूट करवाना है। देन मैं आपको
एक और कमेंट देता हूं यहां पर ताकि
नेक्स्ट पर्पस चल जाए। दिस मैसेज बॉक्स
दिस
दिस मैसेज बॉक्स अपीयर्स
अपीयरर्स ओनली
आफ्टर द यूजर
क्लोज नोटपड
किसके कारण
एंड
ड्यू टू
बी वेट ऑन
रिटर्न इक्वल ट्रू इसके कारण अंडरस्टुड
इसके कारण
उसके बाद चलो फिर एक और मैसेज बॉक्स लिख
देते हैं। मैसेज बॉक्स
यहां पर लिखा डेमो टू नहीं नो नो नो नो
डेमो टू नहीं
नोटपैड
हैज़ बीन क्लोज्ड नोटपैड हैज़ बीन क्लोज्ड
उसके बाद इसको यह किया देन नाउ
मूविंग टू
डेमो टू मूविंग टू डेमो टू ओके ये हो गया
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट डेमो टू में क्या है?
हमने एक और मैसेज बॉक्स मेंशन किया। मैसेज
बॉक्स। उसके बाद ये मेरा डेमो टू क्या है?
डेमो टू। डेमो टू में क्या है? कैलकुलेटर
कैलकुलेटर विल ओपन
ओपन मिनिमाइज्ड।
ओपन मिनिमाइज
एंड द स्क्रिप्ट विल नॉट वेट एंड द
स्क्रिप्ट विल नॉट वेट स्क्रिप्ट वेट नहीं
करने वाली इस केस में अब की बार नेक्स्ट
तो चलो फिर इसके लिए भी लिखते हैं इसके
लिए क्या लिख रहे हैं ऑब्सेल
ओके डॉट रन गुड उसके बाद
सी सॉरी सी एल सी डॉट exc ये है इसका
एग्जैक्ट कैलकुलेटर की एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल
उसके बाद ट्रू उसके बाद फॉल्स उसके बाद
फॉल्स देन फिर से मैंने एक और मैसेज बॉक्स
मेंशन किया मैसेज बॉक्स
नोटिस
दैट
कैलकुलेटर
ओपन
ओपन इन द बैकग्राउंड
ओपन इन द बैकग्राउंड एंड
दिस मैसेज
पॉप्ड
पॉप्ड अप दिस मैसेज पॉप्ड अप इमीडिएटली
पॉप्ड अप इमीडिएटली बिकॉज़
बिकॉज़
बिकॉज़ बी वि
ऑन रिटर्न
इक्वल
फॉल्स
अंडरस्टुड
अंडरस्टुड जो मैं लिखने की सोच रहा हूं।
कंट्रोल
ठीक है। यहां तक आपको समझ में आ रहा है
कोड में क्या हो रहा है? पहले मैंने क्या
किया? नोटपड exc ओपन किया तब स्क्रिप्ट
वेट करेगी आगे नहीं मूव करेगी जब तक क्लोज
ना हो नोटपड उसके बाद नोटपड क्लोज हो गया
डेमो टू आपका कैलकुलेटर ओपन होगा वो किसी
के लिए वेट नहीं करने वाला रन करें इसको
सबको क्लियर है कोड सबको क्लियर है तो
बताओ अगर नहीं है तो भी बताओ
चलो मैं आपके ग्रुप में शेयर कर दूंगा
इसको ठीक है किस-किस ने ग्रुप ज्वाइन किया
यहां पर बताओ इसका मैं स्क्रीनशॉट ले लेता
हूं
तो आपको अच्छे से समझ में आ जाएगा।
ठीक है? स्क्रीनशॉट मैंने ले लिया है आप
लोगों के लिए।
चलो इसको करते हैं रन भैया। इसको करते हैं
रन। तो ए वन 2 3
ओके एंड रन। देखो डेमो वन नोटपड विल ओपन
इन मैक्सिमाइज मोड एंड द स्क्रिप्ट विल
वेट अंटिल नोटपड इज क्लोज्ड ओके करें एंड
ओके नोटपड ओपन हो गया
नोटपड ओपन हो गया देन मैंने नोटपैड को
क्लोज किया नोटपड हैज़ बीन क्लोज्ड नाउ
मूविंग टू डेमो टू
ओके डेमो टू कैलकुलेटर विल ओपन मिनिमाइज्ड
एंड द स्क्रिप्ट विल नॉट वेट। ओके?
कैलकुलेटर ओपन हो गया और यह भी हो गया।
नोटिस दैट कैलकुलेटर ओपन इन द बैकग्राउंड
एंड द मैसेज पॉप्ड अप इमीडिएटली बिकॉज़ बी
वेग ट्रॉ। अंडरस्टुड? क्या हुआ? पूरा कोड
समझ में आ गया?
पूरा कोड समझ में आ गया? यह कैलकुलेटर ओपन
हो रखा है और पूरा कोड भी एग्जीक्यूट
किया। पूरा कोड सबको समझ में आया? क्या
हुआ यहां पर?
पूरा कोड सबको समझ में आ गया? सबको क्लियर
है? फर्स्ट डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट को ऐसे यूज़
किया जाता है। है पावरफुल मैक
मैक पावरफुल है या नहीं है? बताओ।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बिल्कुल है ना यह तो जस्ट छोटी सी पावर
है।
यह छोटी सी पावर है। बहुत कुछ सिखाने वाला
हूं आपको। एमएसएफ वेनम के पेलोड भी हम मै
डेवलपमेंट में इंक्लूड करके दिखाएंगे।
अंडरस्टुड?
हिडन का यूज़ करना है। तो एक काम करते हैं।
हिडन के लिए हम कौन से पैरामीटर हमें यूज़
करना था हिडन के लिए? बताओ।
हम कैलकुलेटर को हाइड करते हैं। ओके? हम
कैलकुलेटर को ही हाइड कर देते हैं। ओनली
कैलकुलेटर को हाइड करते हैं। तो हिडन के
लिए हम यूज़ करेंगे जीरो। तो चलो इसको हम
कर देते हैं यहां पर जीरो।
करें। आर यू गाइस रेडी? चलो।
ओके। डेमो वन पॉप अप। ओके। नोटपड ओपन
क्लोज। नोटपैड हैड बीन क्लोज। ओके। मूविंग
टू डेमो टू। यह लो अभी यह हाइड नहीं हुआ
बिकॉज़ आई डोंट नो कि क्यों नहीं हुआ बट
होना चाहिए था हाइडिंग विंडो क्यों नहीं
काम किया इस केस में मे बी कोई इशू है
ऑब्जेक्ट ऑन CK0 एक काम करते हैं और यह
काम नहीं किया बट करना चाहिए हाइडिंग
विंडो
जीरो क्यों नहीं काम किया एक सवाल है यह
तो बढ़िया सवाल है।
फायरिंग के लिए इसको काम करना चाहिए था।
एक काम करते हैं। हम इसको पूरे को अभी
क्लोज नहीं कर सकते। एंड एंड ये रहा। मैं
इसको अभी बंद करता हूं पूरे को।
मैं इसको फाइल बस।
और ये रहा मैसेज बॉक्स। इसको यहां तक करते
हैं क्लोज।
करना चाहिए भैया। पर क्यों नहीं कर रहा
हूं? तो बहुत बड़ा सवाल देखो।
ठीक है? हाइडिंग क्यों नहीं काम कर रहा
मैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में बता दूंगा और वरना
यह कुछ इशू हो रहा होगा क्योंकि आज काफी
लेट होगी आपकी क्लास। कुछ इशू रहा होगा तो
इसको मैं आपको रिॉल्व कर दूंगा। ओके?
हाइडिंग का एग्जांपल मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा।
और हाइडिंग वाला तो हम यूज़ करने वाले ही
हैं। पावर सेल हाइड भी करेंगे। पावर सेल
ड्रॉपर भी यूज़ करने वाले हैं हम। सब कुछ
सीखने वाले हैं। तो आज की क्लास में सबको
मजा आया? बताओ सीखने को मिला बहुत कुछ?
बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिला।
चलो एक बार फिर से मैं आपको बता देता हूं।
अगर आप लोगों को क्लास के नोट्स चाहिए,
आपको अगर कुछ आपके डाउट्स हैं, तो आपको
आपके डाउट्स आपको मेरे साथ शेयर करने हैं
या आपको आने वाले आने वाली क्लासेस के
जितने भी नोट्स चाहिए प्रीवियस क्लासेस के
नोट्स चाहिए तो प्लीज एक आप लोगों के लिए
स्पेशल tlegram पे मैंने ग्रुप ओपन किया
है जिसको आप ज्वाइन कर सकते हो। वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन लिंक में आपको मिल जाएगा।
क्लास 77, क्लास 78 अगर आप रिकॉर्डेड
वीडियो ही क्यों ना देख रहे हो तब भी आप
उसको क्या कर सकते हो? ज्वाइन कर सकते हो
और ज्वाइन करने के बाद वहां पर आपको नोट्स
आपके
जो डाउट्स हैं वो भी हम ले लेंगे। बिकॉज़
उसमें अभी तक मैंने चैट ऑप्शन ओपन किया
हुआ है। लेकिन एक ही कंडीशन पर हमने वो
चैट ऑप्शन ओपन किया था। वहां पर कुछ भी
फालतू की बकवास बाजी नहीं चाहिए हमें।
ओके? अब डॉक्यूमेंटेशन ये प्रैक्टिस होगी।
मैं समझा नहीं यार।
ओके। तो अगर आप लोगों को समझ में आ गया,
सारी चीजें क्लियर है तो हम सेशन को एंड
करने वाले हैं। और आई होप कि आज की क्लास
में किसी को कोई डाउट नहीं होगा। मैं सेशन
को क्लोज कर देता हूं। ओके?
डोंट सेव।
इसमें आपके लिए मैं इसको कर देता हूं।
कंट्रोल एस इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं। कोई
डाउट है?
जी, मैं कोर्स सेल नहीं कर रहा। मैं फ्री
में पढ़ाता हूं। यहां पर कोई भी आपका पैसा
नहीं लग रहा है। तो आप इसको फ्री में पढ़
सकते हो। मैं सेल नहीं कर रहा। आपके पेड
वाली पेमेंट जो पेड वाले कोर्सेज मैं फ्री
में पढ़ाता हूं। तो आप यहां से इसको फ्री
में पढ़ सकते हो। जो चीज आप एथिकल हैकिंग
में पेड में सीखने की कोशिश कर रहे हो।
उससे कई गुना ज्यादा इसमें है। पूरा एक
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में एक एक सिलेबस की
फॉर्म में यहां पर पढ़ाया जाता है।
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। कल मिलते
हैं। कल भी आपका सेशन होगा। ओके गाइस सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन। गुड नाइट एवरीवन।
बाय-ब टेक केयर। सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
टुमारो। नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट क्लास।